welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this video were
breaking down the haunting of Hill House
when the show first aired on Netflix in
2018 it completely blew me away and
today it stands as my favorite TV show
of all time
it was expertly written had a ton of
hidden things in it and with the release
of its sequel to you later this year now
is the perfect time to revisit it
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the show's hidden twist
ending pointing out all the background
ghosts and also giving our theories on
how it could all just be in the
characters minds there will of course be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet and I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the haunting of Hill House okay so the
haunting of Hill House sent us around
the crane family and it takes place over
two time periods
initially we join them in 1992 as they
purchased the property with the goal of
renovating and selling it however
strange things began to happen and
slowly the group are haunted by the
mysterious ghosts that have it the walls
of the home the mother of the family
Olivia tormented by the spirits has a
complete mental breakdown one night she
tries to poison a children Nell and Luke
and also Luke's best friend
Abigail Dudley she succeeds in killing
the latter and Hugh the father of the
family flees with the children into the
night the second time period is set 26
years later and it focuses on the cranes
dealing with their childhood trauma Nell
returns to the home and apparently hangs
herself and the group are forced to
reunite with one another in order to
save Luke they returned to the house and
in the end Hugh gives himself up to it
in order to free them from its grasp and
he's reunited with his wife and daughter
in the afterlife the rest of the cranes
all go on to confront their demons and
they all lived happily ever after that's
a basic plot overview but there's
actually a lot of things going on in the
series that really make it stand out
firstly are the hidden ghosts which pop
up throughout the season in the
background of scenes I've taken a ton of
notes and watched the entire series on a
large projector
I think I caught them all but if I
didn't make sure you comment below and
let us know if we missed any of the
hidden ghouls I've also used screenshots
as opposed to footage on the whole
because some of these literally appear
on screen for a split second anyway the
first one doesn't appear until 33
minutes and 33 seconds into the first
episode throughout the scene in which
huge talks to Steve about escaping the
property you can barely make out someone
in the corner of the room however when
Hugh picks Steve up and turns to face
the door you can quite clearly make out
a woman standing there and watching them
as they go to leave the property we can
actually see three standing in the door
frames as they run down the stairs the
first is a woman standing under the
archway and the other two are a man and
woman who are standing on the opposite
side the final one in the episode
happens at the 50 minute and 44 second
mark and we can see a man's face behind
some furniture looking over live
shoulder he moves backwards as the
conversation goes on but it's just so
creepy seeing him staring over them in
episode 2 early on at the full minute
marker we can see a woman standing
behind a tree in the garden there's also
a figure that can be seen standing in
the dining room
it looks really blurred and it is
difficult to make out however in the
next shot of a live shoulder we see that
the figure has disappeared so we can
tell that it was a ghost
now the next one isn't a ghost per se
but it does indicate that there may be
one that we just can't see at the 36
minute and 36 second mark we can see
that Olivia's hair falls very strangely
almost like it's being pulled it's a
very subtle detail and one that doesn't
pop up again through the series but I
just thought I'd include it in here as
it is yeah it's just very strange now
episode 3 has the most ghosts in it and
this may be because the episode centers
around Theo who he learned possesses a
sixth sense the first one is in a real
blink in your missing moment that
happens as she walks into the kitchen
and in the top window of the door we can
see a creepy figure staring at her when
she exits the kitchen with Luke later on
we can also see the figure of man
standing in front of a mirror it's very
difficult to see as it is quite obscured
but in motion the person is clearly
there now at the 28 minute and 25 second
mark we can see Theo investigating the
boiler and clearly there is no one
standing in the room with
however in the reverse shot we can see
that there is indeed someone in the room
standing in the corner
not long after Theo opens the trapdoor
and in a blink in your missing moment we
can see someone standing behind the
ladder to get down there and another
blink in your miss at moment at the 38th
minute and seventeen second mark we can
see a woman standing beside the dining
room table 39 minutes and 41 seconds in
has a man standing in a doorway as Theo
walks past it and seconds later we can
then see a woman standing under an
archway looking at Theo and live the
final one for the episode comes at the
50 minute and 52 second mark and it
takes place roughly over a second as the
family run out to meet one another you
can see a man standing behind a
lampshade episode 4 has a couple in it
and at 8 minutes we get the appearance
of two firstly we see an extremely
blurry figure standing behind a chair
and then later in the same minute we see
a woman standing at the bottom of the
corridor she's still quite blurry but
she's a bit easier to make out than the
one that preceded her at the 14 and a
half minute mark we can see two standing
in a doorway as Luke runs down the
stairs similar to Luke they both have
bowler hats and I'll discuss how this
ties in to each person's individual
terror later in the video at the three
minute mark of episode 5 we can see a
woman standing behind lips shoulder it's
very dark in the actual show but if you
turn the brightness up you can clearly
make out the figure Nell it's late a
stalk by your figure under the piano and
though again it's difficult to make out
its face and body you can see its hands
pressed against the floor as it listens
in on their talking with their mother we
also see a figure standing behind the
character at the 23 minute mark and this
one just creeps the hell out of me
episode 6 has a kind of obvious warn at
the 14 and a half minute mark with Nell
standing behind the family as they look
over her body this one is a bit more
subtle but at the 41 minute mark as live
enters the room looking for now we can
see that the statue heads are facing a
certain way however we can later see
that one of them turns when Liv goes
back into the corridor at 42 minutes and
13 seconds we can also see a woman sat
on the bed as live continues a search
for now episode 7 has a very brief one
as Hugh clears out the mold and we can
see a woman staring at him from
behind a pillar later the same woman
appears in the same room with a hand
behind a police officer I guess she must
have had a free schedule that day now
episode 8 doesn't really have many
ghosts in it and this may be because we
see it from Steve's POV and he doesn't
really believe in them however at the
six minute and 45 second mark he does
pass a clock repairman on the stairs
that we later learn as a ghost episode 9
has a lot more than the prior entry and
at the 1 minute 15 mark we can see a man
standing under an archway at 8:09 the
clock fixer is back on the stairs and at
the 8:12 mark we can see a woman in the
kitchen looking at the children through
a window that one that one is designed
to give you nightmares 22 minutes and 48
seconds in and the clock repair guy is
back on the stairs for the final time
and at 35 minutes and 55 seconds we can
see a man standing under an archway as
they say goodbye to live also the motel
that Olivia stays in is the same one
that Nell did before she made a final
visit to the house at 39 34 we can see
the shadow of a woman standing under an
archway and as we know this is a
prominent place for ghosts to stand
about in Olivia also calls Shirley her
kitten which may be a reference to the
dead kittens that Shirley looked after
which we'll talk about in just a bit
episode 10 doesn't really have any
hidden ghosts but there are a craft and
that follows Steve out as he exits the
property this showcases all of the
victims that the house is claiming over
the heirs and lets us know that this
isn't a very nice place now there are a
ton of other moments of foreshadowing
throughout the piece as well for example
when Nell hangs herself though we don't
discover this until much later all of
the cranes wake up at the exact same
moment that it happens and clasp their
throats this is most noticeable in Luke
who has a shared empathy with his twin
sister and therefore he feels it more
Olivia also tells the children that when
the porch light is on that it's time to
come home
when Nell returns home the lights flare
up signaling her to do this she also
sees them at the vending machine before
making the trip back to the house in
Episode two the porch light on the
forever house model flashes to indicate
this and in Episode four when the man
with the bowler hat stalks Luke it is
revealed to be Olivia who shines light
in his face at one point in the series
Theo gets asked if she can feel the cold
spot in the house cold spots and fiction
often indicate that ghosts are present
but Thea replies by saying that the
whole house is cold this doesn't mean
that the temperature is bad and that
they need to get some radiators but it
actually means that it's full of ghosts
which Theo would be more susceptible to
as she has psychic abilities as children
surely in Thea or in a room and they
hear banging on the walls indoors which
scares the life out of them later this
is repeated in the funeral home when
they're arguing a Halloween and it shows
the house often brings things back to
torment the family in Episode four
Olivia also points the stairway and
states that she doesn't like the ropes
there as she can picture bodies hanging
from it this would of course be the spot
at which Yunel ended a life in the very
same manner there's probably a hell of a
lot more but those are the main hidden
aspects within the show but what about
the hidden aspects of its ending well in
order to discuss that we have to discuss
the house itself now from the offer we
get the sense that Hill House is just
pure evil it torches its occupants and
feeds them with hallucinations that
slowly drive them insane it can bend
space and time resurrect the dead and
because of the mold that exists within
the house even the air itself is a
poisonous gas the houses main goal is to
feed upon the living through driving
them to take their own lives and it does
this through carefully curated ghosts
inspectors that prey on the crane
family's worst fears each ghoul an
apparition has been designed with one
goal in mind to bring the family back to
the Red Room which is the houses stomach
so that can feast on them during the
show the house purposely twists and
changes the Red Room so that it appears
to be a safe area in which each member
of the crane family can relax and be
digested teluk it's a tree house Theo
sees a dance studio Steve sees a game
room
Olivia gets a reading room and so on it
is a room which is tailor-made towards
them so that it can feel some sense of
sanity was also being driven insane
there are hints that each member is in
the Red Room throughout the season as
the window is always the same the door
is the same shape whenever is seen from
the inside and the handle is - there are
also subtle lines that show the
scenarios that the room takes on are
also false
when Luke's treehouse is brought up
Olivia says very funny
is discussing his games room with mrs.
Dudley she seems confused and doesn't
know what he's talking about in the room
there are also subtle red choices such
as Steve having a big red beanbag the
netting of the tree house being red and
the big red cover over Olivia's reading
chair in the finale the group are also
given hallucinations when in the Red
Room and there are several clues that
these are indeed fake there is a red
Fry's box a red cardigan Steve's wife
wears a red necklace and Shirley also
wears a red shirt she also sees red
roses when imagining Nell's funeral
Theo's girlfriend is also seen wearing
red underwear and yet put it away lads
so it is safe to say that the house
slowly attracts the family to the room
and then piles them with hallucinations
in order to feed upon them we learned
throughout the show that the house is
operated in this exact same manner for
decades we discovered that the property
was originally home to the hell family
and it managed to eat most of them it
even went so far to cause William Hill
the brick himself behind a wall out of
fear which brings me to my next point
the houses greatest trick is that it
makes people wall themselves off from
the outside world and tricks them into
believing that they're safe within it so
that they refuse to leave does this
successfully to Olivia and almost fools
her into murdering her two youngest
children she does however managed to get
the Dudley's daughter Abigail which in
the long run helps it to stay standing
and the final episode we learn that you
almost burn the house down
but was stayed from doing so by the
Dudley's after Abigail's ghost appeared
to them they realized that the house had
kept his spirit alive and if it were to
be destroyed their daughter would go
with it so they made a deal with the
devil and convinced you to abstain from
setting it alight though by the end of
the season the house is portrayed as a
happy place that one can live on forever
within it is clearly all a ruse just as
it's about to be destroyed it manages to
manipulate the dirt leads into pulling
at the heartstrings of Hugh and they put
him in a position where he would have to
be a monster to deny them it's a smart
move that I haven't seen many people
pick up upon and also allows the house
to continue to lure Nell into returning
and thus the cranes follow not long
after when Nell arrives she is given a
fantasy in which her deceased husband is
no longer dead and this sets off a chain
reaction and we
the rest of the cranes would return and
he would be forced to give himself over
in exchange for their lives similar to
the fantasy that now got we were tricked
into believing that we got a happy
ending when we really didn't the saying
that the house always wins
is definitely true here to me this is
hammered home by the fact that the house
is a clear control over time we discover
that the bent neck lady that haunts Nell
is actually a version of her from the
future the last-ditch attempt at the
moment of a death knell travels back in
time to warn herself but ultimately this
ends up making her return to the house
to commit the act that would lead to her
doing it Nell obviously did not possess
the power to control time itself so this
was the house playing its hand to cause
her to return that so that it could feed
upon her once more it's a brilliant
reveal and it definitely stands as one
of the strongest moments in the show so
in the end though the cranes believe
that they won they really didn't it took
their mother father Nell and the
Dudley's daughter we see in the end that
the Dudley's returned there and died in
the property so also took them to we
learned throughout the season that the
entire Dudley family worked as the
grounds keepers for the house and thus
they were pretty much slaves to it the
cranes will likely return to the house
to see their family when it's their time
to die and thus they will be taken by it
too though we don't know what's gonna
happen in season two yet those are my
main thoughts on the house and how it
operates but there may be a plausible
explanation for everything and that is
the black mold now like all good Horrors
you can really take the events of the
series as being supernatural or not and
the mold really gives us an indication
that the events in the show can be
explained away the black mold is first
found by the family in Episode seven
during which Hugh discovers it's
spreading behind the walls of the house
the father discusses how dangerous that
it is and stipulates that it can cause
problems both physically and mentally
the mold keeps them in the house for
longer than intended as Hugh knows he
must fix it before listing it for sale
now it could be concluded that the mold
is in fact causing all of the health and
hallucination problems that are rampant
throughout the family
the Red Room is said to be the source of
the mold and this is why the problems of
the house stem from there when we
finally get a look inside of it at the
end of episode 10 we can see it is
heavily and best with mold and this
could also be the reasoning behind this
being labeled as the houses stomach the
mold even makes an appearance in
Shirley's model house when we join the
group as adults when it is found in
pieces
Shirley turns it over to find the inner
walls rotting and this could also be
attributed as a cause of the
hallucinations that happen in her home
Luke witnesses the ghost of William Hale
outside of a mold infested area however
he is an addict and these visions could
be put down to his substance abuse when
he returns to the house in the show's
climax the ghost of Olivia informs him
that the other visions he's had of her
during his life or in fact all in his
head this showcases that he can still
hallucinate without there being need for
a ghost present the kittens that are
found died of poor health and as they're
only young they would be more
susceptible to the mold and therefore
their deaths could be put down to it
even in the first episode when Steve is
investigating a ghost at one of his fans
houses he states that there is clearly a
leak and that if the person doesn't get
it looked at it can cause serious damage
a lot of the banging in the house is
explained away as being the pipe work
within and should this burst that the
mold would spread quicker in Episode
nine we discover Olivia's mental illness
came from when her mother and father
died when she was very young she
suppressed the grief and then it hit her
all at once and the mold could have made
these memories resurface you also learn
about poppy Hills a previous occupier of
the home that went insane as did a
husband Steve finds a dresser in Episode
eight and the underneath is laced with
mold
perhaps showcasing the cause of her
insanity the Dudley's two mentioned that
their parents that worked in the house
went insane that their first child was
stillborn
which could be a side effect of the mold
even the bent neck lady can be explained
away by sleep paralysis and Nell's
eventual death could be because she
stopped taking her antidepressants Steve
explains away all of the phenomena in
the opening of the season through
showing the audience that supernatural
things often have a rational element to
them and elevates the show in my opinion
having this side to it well I love about
it is that
season really works either way and the
best ghost stories always offer a way
for skeptics to put the events aside and
whilst I do believe that the apparitions
were real it is fun to consider that
they may in fact not be perhaps the
family is as Steve states suffering from
a mental illness that was brought on by
the house infecting them there's a lot
to digest but I'll let you decide that
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you leave your thoughts in the comments
below you want something else to watch
then check out our insane details in
hereditary which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over all of the hidden
figures and that and the things you
missed so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]